hello how are you guys right foot both
headphones on I'm in yet with three
seats and three use okay Matt Reba come
on Andy Serkis walking a show how's it
going gentlemen have a seat how are you
good I am I'm saying how are you Steve
or how are you man good to see you you
Congrats on the big movie and then
entering into summer blockbuster world
for this year thank you
this is it exciting or is it stressful
just because well now you're talking
about right like spider-man comes out
it's funny oh yeah then you're
mentioning that yeah that's that's the
disaster doesn't how is more manageable
be though nobody want to see that no I
don't think anybody saw that I made it
made 117 million dollars yeah yeah
that's the things we spent you know I
spent literally three years working on
this movie so it's this weird thing
where suddenly you finish it the effects
finish so light that the moment that I
see the movie we have to share the movie
and then all of a sudden it's like now
we're talking about it and it's going to
come out and then there's like it's
hugely competitive time and so you don't
you don't have that like most people
come in and they promote a project and
they're part of their kind of removed
from it because you know they've moved
on to the next thing yeah for sure yeah
this is different than that but yeah
literally the realization of what we do
you know wait you know mark bomback and
I spent almost a year writing it and
then we shot it over the course of eight
months and we were in post on this for
over a year so the idea is that you know
we get these incredible performances
from these guys and then we spend a year
working on the cut and working with
Wetty the amazing artists that Wetty
to shot-by-shot make sure that you are
feeling the same thing looking at these
apes that we felt looking at these
actors and that is a hard process what
it takes so long it's what is the
biggest mistake somebody makes they're
doing motion capture it's not an easy
thing to do so what is the biggest thing
that people do that screws it up well
the biggest thing is that people
misunderstand what the process is
because performance capture is just a
series of cameras and the performances
are what it's about so it's the one
place where you know visual effects are
all about realizing the performance and
you know people talk about Andy's being
the greatest mocap actor of all time
it's a nonsensical idea because what
that is is basically a system that
records a performance what he is is one
of the best actors in
world brothers to screw up the motion
capture is to suck well good yeah that's
it that's it yeah I'm so you're a
terrible actor you won't be good
it's any fun yeah you know often you do
in your chimp is horrible and you don't
yeah then it's a bad
it's truly that I mean it's if you're
good you know the technical people on
set the crazy thing that I learned I
couldn't you know I was new to this
right and I showed up in the technical
artist the Wetty people are not like
this separate group they are as involved
when you're shooting there is excited
about a good scene as anybody because
they know then wow we got something
awesome this is going to be violent and
we're going to have to you know how do
we how do we how do we put this together
how do we make that work yeah you know
and it's not about the big scene with
explosions it's about that the the push
in close-up that you shot like any other
movie where you know it pushes into Andy
and you see this you know 17 emotions in
this guy's face which is amazing yeah
how do we do that how do the thing we're
feeling right now you feel two years
from now what's great it is crazy so
it's like any other role there's a way
to do it right there's a way to screw it
up basically check to be which we care
exactly I mean it's to be truthful and
honest and emotionally connect with the
other other actors that you're working
with and that's the bottom line you know
there is this crazy mystery that
surrounds this performance capture stuff
and it's it's it comes from other actors
it comes from a perception but they have
to say that is check that is changing
but but it's like Steve say like Matt
saying you know you you can't you can't
make look if someone does a really bad
performance in a in a live-action movie
you can't do anything about that you
can't do it you know you can cut around
it but you can't make that performance
any better and it's exactly the same
with motion capture performance capture
cameras they're just another way of
recording an actor's performance so you
can't you know you have to find it on
the day it's not that that you can't
augment the performance
you what that's where they think people
get mixed up about it you know the whole
point is that you you want to have these
great performances on the day between
actors and then and then you they
finally get cloaked and transferred onto
these onto the faces of these Apes and
they're made believable and that's and
made to you know what they what weatr
are extraordinary and I've been working
with them for 17 years and and and and
they've reached a point now where they
are so the fidelity of what they do in
in terms of honoring the acting
performances and and the way they render
those characters now to make them
believable a second to none but I think
people also like they don't understand
because it's so new you know I mean as
far as film good it's very new and I
think that people like when they see
either Caesar or bad ape or Gollum or
any of these characters they associated
as voiceover know know what I mean it's
sort of when and it's not what it is
yeah they're actually you know it's so
much more than that the performances the
performance but the way they move there
it's a series of cameras and tracking
markers on a performer and that
performance is what it's all about the
way they move everything the emotion
that they're feeling and expressing on
their faces that is what the captures
are what the cameras are capturing and
then that's what we edit together we
edit together the first version of this
movie is planet of the mocap actors and
that version of the movie is awesome
it worked that means as a director
though you have to visually see what's
going to be there I do and but with the
actors it's much less hard than you
would think because what I'm looking at
is the emotion if the emotion of the
scene is working that I know is what
we're going to have the hardest part is
then making sure that what it gets all
of that because you know that's thing
you know when I came in as a crash
course on on dawn because I hadn't done
performance capture and I asked to see
every single shot of Andy and every
single shot of Cesar because I didn't
quite understand the process yet and I
was like oh that's it the reason that I
feel this way is because Andy's
incredible and what I actually said to
them was first of all what you guys did
is amazing and yet I see detail in his
performance emotionally like in a moment
when he's enraged but you can see the
sadness in his eyes that's even more
emotional than what Caesar is Andy's
better than Caesar and I was like we
have to push and see if
we can get as much of what he's done
into Caesar and I knew from seeing Rise
that I was terribly affected by what
he'd done but he's an incredible actor
and the goal is to try and get
everything that these guys are doing and
make it visible on those Apes face do
you guys now when you do a role like
this do you think too much credit like
because people talk about motion capture
do you think too much credit is given to
the computers and After Effects and they
don't realize like hey that's actually
just what we did no not a know how that
is right as valid credit to it it's not
that's an amazing process those guys are
I mean that that whether that that is an
amazing group of artists that keep
getting better and better
it has nothing about it this competition
it's just it's hard to have gone through
a process where you're so proud of your
work as an actor to have look it's hard
to play a teacher okay it's it's harder
to play a teacher who's a chimpanzee and
then you master that and you you bust
your ass for six months literally and
then you read in the end a thing like
lends his voice to the right that's
enough if I was you know at Rome and I
flew in a couple times in and they sent
me a check to show up in sweatpants and
just do a funny accent boys and yeah
when my voice what are you kidding yeah
but also you know the artists at wetter
would be the first to tell you that they
they're following the performance this
is the idea of the technology the
technology is recording a performance
because they want to use that
performance and it is incredible what
they do I mean there is there are two
groups of amazing artists that make this
illusion possible first are the actors
and they're the ones who are baring
their souls and the other are the
incredible artists who not only are
doing you know they've got these
simulations that they're doing to make
the hair the Apes look more real in this
movie then they have this is a high
watermark for these effects but the
other aspect of that is an
interpretation of these performances
because the anatomy that is on these
guys faces is not the Anatomy that's on
the Apes faces so somehow they have to
take those same shapes and make sure
that we see them in a way that keeps the
ape looking believable right they're
still feeling so there's a tremendous
artistry that these guys who are doing
that have and and so it's it's
just the people who are at who do this
we have the best actors in the world and
we have the best artists at Wetty in the
world and how much time do you guys also
good know I was just saying like it and
and we shoot this on location
yeah understand that either yeah I think
you're in a room right you know
throughout me hello these guys are in
the end it was a fake background and
those guys did but but this was yeah if
you see smell it looked cold it was cold
if we're wet where we were wet you know
running up of the rainforest Hill that's
that's exactly what we did and that's
what blew me away I showed up I was like
wow we're this is we're on horseback
okay yeah doing that stuff yeah and I
have to get off the horse and I'm
thinking okay I get to get off the horse
I can't get off as Steve is pretending
to be a cowboy yeah I have to get off
effortlessly like I'm a little chimp and
rightly excited how the hell am I going
to do that without throwing my back out
didn't you have physical problems during
it none of your business man come on
just tell me come on guy died ah the
first thing I wanted to ask no it has
nothing to do the booth no I did
constantly look I to be honest with you
I stretch I stretch three times a day
I took Epsom salt baths that first two
weeks I was in pain man I never let
these guys know this because it's Andy
Serkis you know and they I mean I was so
nervous could be a dip for realize never
I've never been more scared in my life
now there's one time on stage but that
was yeah um but yeah it was really a the
most physical job since I had done
theaters and how do you prepare for that
that's not my - yet like I know you to
prepare for a role some people immerse
themselves in it so what do you do do
you like you actually spend time around
84 go to a zoo or do you know watch
video or how do you get ready for that
Terry notary is it plays rocket right
knee he's amazing amazing actor but an
amazing coach he was a great coach and
and I came into it late so Annie was
already working so I was just with Terry
and Terry started we just started like
breathing and you know looking at each
other and talked
about core and center and you know I
thought we were just going to run around
and pretend we were eight you know but
it started that this really you know
internal place and then I went to my
apartment I spent you know this is my
job so I get two and a half weeks to
prepare
I literally prepared every waking second
of the day I was I was watching videos I
was fascinated with chimps why is that
chimp just sitting in the corner doing
nothing different than me sitting in the
corner doing nothing and I would just I
was constantly working on it to the
point where it became second nature and
then I could play a character because
that's the main thing I have to play
this mountain-man guy who's old order
yeah you know yes afraid of everything
is it is it scary to come into a
franchise like this that's fairly
beloved you know I'm a big fan of the
whole franchise and I love this third
movie by the way but your character is a
comic relief character and that can be
it's not done right it was done right
here but if not done right that that's
been the kiss of death another mo
totally I agree but the only thing that
I I didn't see him as a comic relief
character obviously I'm not stupid and I
know that this is going to add some
levity just because he's different speed
than these guys but I saw that character
as a very tragic this guy went up had to
escape and live he's been living on his
own for two years his friends are dead
the only ways kept his sanity by
hoarding stuffed animals and crap yeah I
know yeah and he comes across these guys
and and he's so need of companionship
you know and he goes against his
instincts to really take them to where
they want to go and I I thought it was
he moved me the character was beautiful
to me and it's vulnerable little guy but
you know I'm gonna have to say the
reason that that I cast Steve was
because we did he came in and we we
actually met over Skype he was down
doing a TV series in Puerto Rico we had
these conversations and he was really
talking about how much he loved the
movies and loved Andy and was like this
you know I'm really excited about this
because
Rolle really moves me and we started
talking about you know being father's
and he started doing one of the scenes
and I started crying because there's a
scene between you know the scene where
where they both talk about their
children yeah and it it's the core of
the character and yes he's humorous but
that seems not funny right and and that
was the core of what Steve did is very
emotional
yeah but there's a binocular thing that
where I thought that was that was the
only we now talk about this really not
good right just say that but it's the
only stroke again to eat attention but
that was the only time where I thought I
don't know those girls even had
binoculars yeah I know you it's totally
worth oh hey guys I got a laugh at the
screening I went today so yeah yeah
people want a couple people want to call
in and ask you guys questions um
Pancho from Texas hell hello good
morning I think my pleasure is to end
the how much has way dose technology
advances for made or the reins to now I
mean you go to the Hobbit cheese you see
what they did with uh with Smaug and
stuff like that and also and uh see if I
love that movie Knights of Badassdom
right now dude so so yeah so in terms of
the technological advancements yeah I
mean it's what's been incredible is when
we shot Lord of the Rings at the time it
was that we were only able to use motion
capture cameras to capture the physical
aspects of what I was doing as Gollum
and then the animators had to copy my
facial expressions from from film so
they literally were rotoscoping or
painting over my facial expressions and
then when we started working on King
Kong that that was the first time that
we were able to put markers dots on our
faces and that was right like driving
for the first time a digital mask of a
character but it was inside a studio and
it was like an array of cameras which
were 180 degrees so you had to face in
one particular direction and then the
next film I did we started to use head
mounted cameras which meant that we were
freed up we were not tethered to
anything we could move around when we
started to work on rise dawn and war
what we started to do is to take
everything out as Steve was saying
earlier on location so
shooting in the first film in the house
that Caesar was brought up in and and
and the laboratory and this and the ape
sanctuary and then with Matt when he
came on board with Dawn wanted to take
things out into the open we we shot in
rainforests and now we're shooting in
mountains and snow and all that kind of
stuff so the technology has become more
robust and the cameras and the suits
that we work and cope with with with all
these conditions but what has also
radically changed is is the artistry is
the ability to to actually that whether
this incredible group of CG artists know
now how to take the performance the
facial performance and map it onto to
the the face of an ape in such a to such
a high degree and which makes them
everything much more believable ever
thank you thanks Michael I have a
question for Steve that doesn't have to
do with to save some movie there was a
reunion recently of a band called vo
nedar's I don't know if you've if you've
heard this and all the Oneidas that's
what I'm but uh you were not there for
the reunion of the wonders now in there
why were you not there because I don't
like those guys they don't try to avoid
the Hospice's don't bring up that movie
yeah no I'm very clean tom average God
still one of my best friends out uh yeah
I was busy like I couldn't do it we
tried to work it out earlier later and I
was busy shooting a pilot and in
Vancouver honking man Coover yeah and uh
I couldn't make it we're just going at
it was embarrassing because they used my
if they held my picture up right like
what like I said yeah it was a bummer
I'm and I've gotten a lot of flack for
that and I deserve it but I couldn't do
anything about it right and it was my
daughter's birthday and she had a lot of
excuse you were busy I had a lot of
excuses yes they were valid yeah yeah
yeah I didn't but does the family guy
does it bother your mind how popular
that movie still is I love it yeah such
a great movie it really is it was a huge
experience I mean that was a you know
early on you get in jobs like that you
know Tom Hanks was is quite a mentor and
he taught us a lot and then it you're
young you get spoiled you know you have
something to ask
it nothing to move on to the night you
think you know you you and you don't
appreciate it at the time and you go how
you and then you think they're all going
to be like that like really fun and
challenging and and in with wonderful
people and then it's it's rare yeah rare
and that's why I honestly this this job
here it was was equivalent to that
really just in the sense of the work how
hard it was how challenging how that
this crew was just when you work with
just brilliant people mm-hmm then
everybody's really confident no one has
to no one has pretense no ones no one's
pulling crap on said there's no drama
you just have excellent people around
each other it's a joy and I want to ask
Matt to if you about directing
Cloverfield because you got a lot of the
people like people loved her hated I
happen to love it because I thought was
amazing but people are like aw man it
made me motely sick like was x times
that was about big furnaces of the film
is that people got nauseous because of
the camera mine but I loved I thought
that was amazing that you get to not
really know and I may be a little bit
but it didn't bother me because I
thought that's what you would do it
really was I mean the idea was to look
I'm very into being very specific and
rigid about point of view and the point
of view of that movie was from this
handycam and there you know light little
handy cams and what you know it's
interesting when we were when we were
making the movie we were looking at it
on you know in a theater and we would
project it and that didn't seem to be a
problem l didn't seem to have the kind
of shaking that would be an appalled
Greengrass movie you know didn't seem
like that but it was interesting then we
started going and looking at in stadium
seating and in stadium seating theaters
where people are kind of sort of stacked
up and looking right at it there I think
it made me a little nauseous it was it
was not the intention to make anyone
sick I'm very sorry and Steve somebody
want to ask about your a your HBO show
what was yours your show May oh yeah yes
with Wendell Pierce and I guess they
want to this once said if they love your
show oh yes the that's one of those
shows that's yeah well last for a long
time David Simon mean he's just a genius
and it was four years of like being on a
doctor
why I guess I was it was just advantage
course yeah pretty much I mean was four
years I mean yeah I've done a show that
was for four seasons and no one saw it
but that's the beauty of HBO yeah what
do you my mother so happy that I was
like we did four years four years yeah
when you do the roles like especially
you Andy like this one like I talked
about in Jim's talking about it before
like stuff that we do we find difficult
to watch is when you look at the screen
do you see yourself like when you see
Caesar we see Gollum when you see any of
these characters do you see like that's
me the same way you would see it if it
were not a motion-capture character
definitely I mean because you're for all
your facial expressions are they're all
your choices who you are as a person you
know what level of putting yourself
under the microscope has gone into the
character you know that this meeting of
I mean there's it is like a digital mask
if you like but at the same time it's
moving it's it's if you put on
prosthetic makeup beforehand you
wouldn't see half of the expressions of
like rational of course the original
guys in there John John John Chambers
makeup you know they literally had to
fight against this foam and rubber but
that was it this encasing their face it
nose twitches is pretty much the
movement as yeah although you know so as
I'm sharing a documentary and Kim Hunter
was so saying they just had to throw our
faces around a guy yeah yeah just to get
any sort of movement into these things
of course you don't have to do any of
that with this is you play it much more
internally and and and and subtly and
this these guys are just miraculous at
transferring your internal emotions and
the subtlety of it like Steve was saying
earlier in a close-up we are not doing
anything but thinking or believing and
and and being in emotional space of the
character that is that is that is what
this does so beautifully how amazing is
it for you to have as much information
as you do about the new Star Wars movie
knowing how much people want to know
even the smallest kernel feel a great
sense of power you do don't you
I really do and I like to torture people
with it and I like to people make people
feel really
really kind of like you know at my beck
and call and I really project yeah what
they're missing out and you have the
liner notes I know what's happening in
the universe these are all tubers
somebody somebody's a question for you
Steve yes Derek hey Steve uh what's : I
have to say I watched your scene where
you shoot Bigfoot on strange wilderness
at least once a week it's one of the
boys a lot yeah epic scene so you smoke
pot huh actually no I just was curious
if the guys Jim and Sam have seen that
because I've seen that film that's
laughs though I gotta say that I've
watched the scene once a week but I am
familiar with it with the work yeah man
that was oh my god making that movie
I've never laughed that hard it was a
that was one of those movies that it was
really hard for me I screwed up a lot it
takes with Justin Long and Jonah Hill
and Kevin Heffernan and I mean those
guys are just so funny and I had to play
this kind of straight guy oh my god just
so hard and then the the reasoning
behind a Bigfoot committing okay yeah
it's rying to come up with it around a
fire what do we say that's all I had all
right Thank You Derek and it does it get
frustrating like the way we talk about
how people don't understand what it is
that you do specifically what both you
did on this on this film is it
frustrating to not get the recognition
whether it be from award shows or
elsewhere that a lot of people feel that
you deserve it's yeah it's finally
frustrating that people don't understand
the process that's the only thing that's
the only thing I'm interested in is is
people fully understanding what we do
and you know and I've become this kind
of de facto spokesperson for it but I
mean the great thing is as more and more
actors come
and play these roles you know Mark
Rylance doing The BFG and you know
graters like Steve coming in and doing
about it you know there's its we won't
be having this conversation forever you
know in ten years time we'll just be
able to talk about the movie of war for
the Planet of the Apes you'll be able to
talk about what it means and what it is
and that's let's think about this this
week because so much kind of import is
put onto the process and actually my aim
would be that people just think of these
guys just acting it's just a different
way of capturing their performance and
now we can talk about what the movie
means right it's not such a conversation
about like oh it looks really really
good you're like no it's a really real
the rule is real yeah it looks like a
real real say no it is you're just
watching the movie like one of those
white paintings where you're touching it
to figure is it just a painting or no
well it's new to the story the fact that
it's this good to see that was it always
took you out of movies we could always
see you know the puppet strings or
whatever it was and now you can't see
them anymore I think we're all just
amazed this [ __ ] looks so good thing
about Cloverfield that all the pressure
was on clover fields they're like what's
the monster going to look like and if it
didn't look like it was like you wanted
it to look like it's not scary that's
not what a monster why we didn't show
the movie that I mean that monster that
much brighter the whole idea yeah right
you you're like what was that
we got glitches with that thing at the
end in the water supposed to be this
thing landing was that what that why was
the thing landing okay good I just
thought it was seven years ago yeah I
did hear yeah but I think somebody at
the point after what that was no I have
to go back and watch it again I think
was the intention for that movie to have
a sequel because there's also the the
voltage of voices and the credits like
that that tape that comes on and like
everybody all that evidence was there
yeah it is there uh you know we may do a
sequel one day I mean the thing is is
that we talked about doing a sequel JJ
Andrew and I and we all just got really
busy and everybody was doing stuff and
then JJ was like hey you know maybe
maybe the sequel the Cloverfield isn't a
sequel at all maybe this is like the
twilight zone and we could do all these
stories right which is really cool yeah
and and he said but you know that
doesn't mean we still couldn't do it
because it would be part of that world
so who knows what we'll do it's a yeah
we had talked we had talked about doing
you know I always thought I deliberately
did a thing where there's a moment where
they're on the Brooklyn Bridge and he
crosses paths with
another person who's documenting the
night and I thought each person has a
story that night absolutely I thought
that there was a you had the potential
just to imply that there were lots of
stories from different perspectives the
same exact same movie different
perspectives yeah now it's a different
story